nicolas pellerin roy analyste en cyber
sécurité à la chaire raoul dandurand
bonsoir mon bon monsieur fillion cette
cyber attaque est la plus importante à
ce jour contre une infrastructure aussi
névralgique aux états unis qu'est-ce qui
est en danger avec cette attaque est ce
qui est en danger toute avancée une
infrastructure même des coloniaux mais
au-delà de ça avec l'internet des objets
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui tout dépendant
de caen a été arrêtée attaque ça peut se
ça peut se répercuter ça puisse se
propager rapidement à tout ce qui est
carter ou le long du dubai klein et tout
ça donc toutes ces données le qui
peuvent autant des données
administratives que des données qui
servent à réguler modéré même prévoir
certaines de certains entretiens et donc
il s'agit d'un rang son logiciel un
logiciel malveillant qui est installée
pour pour 1 crypté des données puis
ensuite on exige une rançon pour
débloquer les données
quelle est l'importance de la rançon
dans ce cas ci est ce qu on a une idée à
l'importance avant son nom elle était
pas encore dévoilée par contre c'est
vraiment à la discrétion de du groupe
criminel en fait seulement ce qu'ils
vont faire c'est qu'ils vont demander un
montant forfaitaire en fonction
autant de l'importance du parc
informatique de l'entreprise que le site
a testé payer parce qu'au fond à
l'entreprise criminelle son objectif
premier c'est bien sur deux d'avoir
d'obtenir l'argent donc demandé une
rançon faramineuse serait se tirer grand
pied donc mais où on peut avoir subi à
connaître par exemple il rend son cul
dernièrement ça doit souvent se chiffrer
en millions d'eur certainement et qu'est
ce qu'on sait du groupe de pirates qui
est derrière la cyber attaques web et
c'est un side en fait c'est un groupe un
groupe important peut-être pas dedans
les plus dans les plus connus et
en introduction vous avez dit qu'ils
étaient associés à un groupe russe par
contre on peut se défendre des traces
aussi 1 1 et a donc le temps dira par
contre sion union une éthique quand même
assez élastique en fait il se targue de
ne pas s'attaquer par exemple au web aux
systèmes de santé des différents pays et
à la suite de cette attaque le contre
coloniaux ils ont manifesté en fait
l'intention de modérer les les cibles
éventuelles de leurs de leur équipe pour
pas que créer en fait des conséquences
sociales désastreuses
ah oui donc on a on a des groupes
criminels avec une certaine éthique
élastique toutefois mais ils ont
manifesté sans vraiment dans les narines
et un jour
façon de parler en effet après avoir été
attaqué une entreprise comme coloniale
se relève commandes de ce qu on vient
aux opérations normales est faut payer
la rançon
ça c'est un enjeu éthique en fait
monsieur fillion que chi chi chi qui
taraude tous les dirigeants en fait
c'est à dire quand vous êtes un andres
intelligent entreprise et que vous
faites bloqué vous retirez informatique
vous avez des sueurs froides en premier
et après ça vous voulez le plus
rapidement possible rétablir vos vos
exercices exactement donc vous pouvez
tenter de payer la rançon certains le
font certains aussi vont négocier avec
le groupe criminel pour faire descendre
ses moteurs mais on comprendra que payer
des rançons les pauses encouragé ni par
lit par les états ou les différents
corps policiers c'est à dire que en
payant la tension pourrait en fait une
certaine un certain marché une certaine
une certaine demande et c'est pour ça
que par exemple des compagnies
d'assurance comme axa en france qui en
ferait une belle assurance pour couvrir
ce genre de rançon logiciel se sont
retirés en fait ce type de service de ce
marché parce que les les groupes
criminels et qui effectue dans son
logiciel attaquer davantage les
entreprises souris en fait parce qu'il
sait ça sur un certain rôle exactement
ça vient stimuler donc 2
de faire d'autres attaques finalement
c'était intéressant de voir la maison
blanche ce midi ce pas vouloir s'engager
dans le débat sur la rançon en disant m
bia est dit que c'est pas une chose à
faire on sait que l'entreprise privée
gère ses affaires de son côté les
rançons j ciel ciblent de plus en plus
des activités stratégiques la com et
pippin par exemple à travers le monde
pourquoi comment ça s'explique ainsi que
vous avez ils s'attaquent à des
infrastructures non seulement d'été
plaît mais on a aussi des hôpitaux des
administrations publiques qui sont les
vrais logique comme vous l'avez dit ou à
la société en fait donc en s'attaquant
des choses comme ça qui sont nécessaires
primordial on stimule en fait on incite
davantage
en fait on met une pression sur ses
administrations là pour qu'elle paie
alors et avec les cyber assurance par
exemple il ya autre chose mais pour ces
groupes criminels là il ya un apport qui
est très tentant la télé par exemple oui
allez-y en fait cio en 2020 par exemple
aux états unis 2 560 centre hospitalier
qui ont été attaqués 27 en france
l'année dernière
mais et si ça a mené le maquereau
injecter 1 milliard d'euros en fait le
marché des semences curité en europe et
c'est un fléau en ce moment partout à
travers le monde vous c'était des gens à
monter avec les wanna cry et tout ça
mais depuis depuis l'avènement de la
cuvée 2009 et lé travail et tout ça
c'est un phénomène de plus en plus
fréquents monsieur peu vrai roi merci
beaucoup pour ses explications ce soir
merci à vous monsieur fillon pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit
oh